the last time she worked in Hollywood as
a screenwriter it wasn't the best of
times for her or for us it was in her
phrase a time of scoundrels she was
summoned before a congressional
committee the house on American
Activities Committee that was in fact a
travesty of human rights
she offered to testify about herself but
refused to speak about anyone else
she was blacklisted and for years unable
to earn her living as a writer but she
returns to us tonight for conscience
intact still a lover of films it is with
great pride that I introduce to you my
friend
Lillian Hellman
and very grateful to you thank you very
much
sorry
let's eat okay thank you very much thank
you I had two reasons for coming so long
a distance to stand here tonight
I like documentary pictures and have
long had a feeling that when they are
good they are not only a high form of
camera expression but important part of
world history the true scholar of
history and the true student of history
must of course be primarily interested
in interpretation but one can easily
make out a case that with more facts
facts before their eyes facts and there
is from a soundtrack the meaning would
come without wrangling and the depth of
the meeting without quibble for the
young what could be better than to see
on film what is hard sometimes was hard
to understand sometimes in quite heavy
prose the faces the speech of real
wedded men and women in peace and in war
in the article on a southern rock when
shown by a good and true documentary
filmmaker leave us alone to test
ourselves such filmmakers from the very
earliest days to these have often worked
in danger one thinks of the wonderful
pictures of the Spanish Civil War and
World War two and they have always
worked without sufficient reward these
men are in many ways the advance
soldiers of picture-making and it is
possible that those of us who write or
direct fiction stand on their shoulders
and should at the very least say thank
you my second reason for being here is
perhaps only important to me
I was once upon a time a respectable
member of this community
respectable didn't necessarily mean more
than I took a daily bath when I was
sober didn't didn't spit except when I
meant to and mispronounced a few words
of fancy French then suddenly even
before Senator Joseph McCarthy reached
for that rusty and poisoned axe I and
many others were no longer acceptable to
the owners of this industry possibly
they were men who had been too busy to
define personal
or National Honor possibly but certainly
they confronted the wild charges of Joe
McCarthy with a force and courage of a
bowl of mashed potatoes I have no
regrets for that period maybe you never
do when you survive but I have a
mischievous pleasure in being restored
to respectability understanding full
well that a younger generation who asked
me hiraman tonight meant more by that
invitation than my name on my history I
thank them for that because I never
thought it would happen and to make them
and myself feel better I hope that the
rest of my life will not be too
respectable
the nominees for documentary short short
subjects are American shoeshine Sparky
green producer Blackwood Tony Antonelli
and Andy Thompson produces the end of
the road John Armstrong producer number
our days John Lichtman producer universe
Lester Navroz producer sorry and the
award goes to number our days Lynne
Lippmann
I can't think of a greater honor than to
receive this from this helmet thank you
this film was a collaboration filled
with love between Barbara Meyerhoff and
myself and I think that feeling spilled
over into our wonderful editor Lewis
Teague our cameraman Neil Wright Klein
I'd like to thank Public Television for
allowing me to break all the rules and
spend a little more money than I should
have
I'd like to thank the man I loved for
not allowing me to break us up and
mostly the magic came from dr. Meyer
Hoff and from the incredible old people
who led us into their lives they gave me
an image of my Jewish heritage and
hopefully of the exuberance of old age
thank you
the nominees for the feature
documentaries are Harlan County USA
Barbara Kopple producer Hollywood on
trial James Guttman and David Halpern
jr. produces off the edge
Michael Firth producer people of the
wind and the [ __ ] and David cuff
produces volcano and inquiry into the
life and death of Malcolm Lowry Donald
Britton and Robert Duncan produces and
the winner is Harlan County USA
can't think of a greater honor than to
be given this award by lillian hellman
many people worked on this film donating
their time and energy and without it it
could never have been made but I accept
this award on the behalf of the miners
of Harlan County who took us into their
homes trusted us and shared their love
with us and it is their commitment and
loyalty which is honored here tonight
thank you very much